I think modern women like being cheated
on do you think but that's because but
that's because modern women think men
are monogamous
no I'm just saying only one out of three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year if you wanted a man
that didn't cheat you could find one
pretty yes but they're the ones that
you're not attracted to you what what
monogamous men that often might not
cheat on you aren't the ones that women
are attracted to because women like men
that are like alcohol well women find 80
of men unattractive so most women are
sleeping out of their league or dating
out of their league and so if you choose
to do that that's what comes with it
yeah and most of them guys that everyone
goes for is going to be a select pack
yeah yeah that's but that's the thing
yeah so I'm saying like if we like those
guys how can we be mad that they cheat
because there's lots of guys that don't
and I think this is the problem is
because in society now where we don't
allow men to be polygamous especially in
the Western countries and then that's
the men that are often caught in
cheating and families are breaking
whereas like parts of Asian Africa where
polygamy is a lot more accepted men have
their children multiple wives and they
raise them and their society is a lot
more stable why don't you think that the
owners should be on the men to know what
they can and cannot do so for me if you
know that you're a man who wants to have
multiple women you should know what you
want and you should make that clear 100
so 100 I don't I'm not here for you
being in a monogamous Village because
I've had guys say that where they're in
a monogamous relationship they cheat and
then they come and tell me Well by
Nature our men are not me yeah babes
then you should have known that you
should not be anyone yeah a caveat
though I think most of the modern men
don't want a second wife they want a
side piece so they want to remain
monogamous to the one that they love but
they have the local news
you know what's crazy that there are
women who want open relationships too so
you just have to find that for me but
for me I have an issue with dishonesty
when you when a woman communicates to
you and lets you know that she just
wants she wants to monogamy and you say
I want that too but then that's not the
reality of what you're living because
there are women there's there's somebody
for everybody so if you want Hunter if
you want to be with someone and you
don't want to be tied down I think women
are in a different age now where a lot
of women don't actually want to be tied
down too so you can easily find that but
I think that women aren't honest with
ourselves and like kind of lie because
I'm sorry A lot of times girls will date
a guy and they know he's a cheater yeah
they know he gets girls it's like what
did you think would happen even even
there's a lot of women that entertain
men that are in relationships or yeah
married or even you know there's there
was a guy that actually like he's he
speaks on uh polygamy well polygeny so
the man being able to have multiple not
women and um so he recently sort of
messaged me about you know would I
insane him and I said does your person
know
you know that's your status and he was
like no I said why would I intern a man
who speaks about it but isn't practicing
it do you get what I mean like if you
come correct that's something I can
consider if it's a part of my lifestyle
but if you're gonna lie and then lie
like why would I be entertaining that
also that's not really Genie if your
partner is not aware yeah
they are very aware of their position
they're very aware that there's
otherwise there's other girlfriends
stuff like that exactly sir you're
cheating yeah exactly do you think if we
accept cheating the first time you're
basically saying it's okay no the rest
yeah yes because I I feel like if you
accept it the first time and you said
okay you can cheat and I will stay then
why would he not do it again but I feel
like a man will cheat regardless whether
you stay or you don't because you could
be then technically single and you will
go back and forth with him for months or
years now
I think that I don't think staying the
first time will enable like will mean he
can carry on doing he's gonna get away
with that I think that people are first
of all people are humans I think that
when we get in relationships we have
this idea of like ownership with people
and I think that is I think that's a
that's not a good thing so people are
humans humans make mistakes and I think
sometimes as well unfortunately some
people don't know what they have until
you're at the point of kind of losing it
and there are some men who they cheat
one time and they realize that actually
that why did I do that kind of like that
doesn't I could lose they realize what
they have and they what they could lose
and so it kind of it change that they
don't cheat again I know I've been like
that but at the same time even two years
you'll do the same thing again I don't
believe that because I know real life
men who have cheated once I don't know
they haven't they get better right 50
years if you want to be like married
long term 50 years is a long time people
are their habits
feel like men cheat more when you tell
them not to or when you put pressure for
them to have to be monogamous
when women talk about Alpha but oh those
are not the men that we like well the
two men that cheated on me I want to
call them I made them the alpha period
so they weren't somebody that those
Ordinary People one was really obese it
wasn't like anybody that anybody else
would want
so I've made them the alpha so as far as
I'm concerned if a man's gonna cheat
they're gonna cheat that is a word
because because everybody's done about
this Alpha you can get a man that's like
an ordinary everyday man like what they
were and according to her you are as a
woman you make them your Alpha so nobody
was looking at them as an alpha you know
it's some guys here and that that is
such a word because some guys are not
what Society what a lot of women see as
desirable but I think I think there's
something in menu that when a woman
likes them
they just think oh I feel like it makes
them feel like
this yeah there's a ego boost and so
then they start walking in that spirit
and then they think I can do anything I
want to do no but wait what you're
basically saying is that you understand
why men behave the way to behave but you
still get angry at the way they behave
because
honesty no because think about this way
yeah and this is where societies geared
towards women like men have to sacrifice
what they have to do naturally to
conform to what a woman wants a man
wants to spready seed that's what he's
driven to do so no that's what he's
driven to do so I always say that men
should have practice discipline I've
done so myself because I know it's
important to successful monogamous
relationships however because women are
given sex like you're born with value in
terms of the sexual Marketplace a man
has to earn his right to have sex so
when he sees an opportunity he's gonna
take it more time as if he lacks
discipline and can I just say that I
believe that most of the time
it's nobody wants these men until he's
got a woman yeah serious
and it's not like the women don't know
oh he's got he's got he's got a woman
if he didn't have a woman I don't think
that they would want that man but it's
just that they always want a man that
somebody else is gone
that just makes it easy for the men to
cheat yeah it's pre-selection like so
historically like we wanted men that got
other women because it was a sign that
he could take care of us too if he could
take care of them and that's the thing
coming back to Eddie's point I think
what Society doesn't realize is that men
don't have to cheat if you want multiple
partners that you're going to be
responsible for which I think is
possible you need to be honest and do it
but it's this whole okay I can jump from
this girl to this yeah
I don't think I don't think most men
want two wives That's like two headaches
if you've seen
this is the problem with men you don't
want it because you can't handle it but
then you don't want to be monogamous if
you can't be monogamous be
AST don't be with one person why would
they why would they have to why would
they like I mean I'm sorry if you're in
the top 10 20 of guys they don't have to
just be as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible